Hypothermic intraperitoneal
chemotherapy, or HIPEC,
is a treatment option for
patients with advanced cancers
that have spread to the
abdominal cavity or peritoneum.
Doctors begin with what is
called cytoreductive surgery
to remove all visible tumors
in the abdominal area.
The extent of the surgery
depends on the findings
during surgery.
Surgery can involve
the removal of tumors
in the upper and lower
abdominal area on the omentum,
on the liver, stomach, small
intestine, colon, rectum,
pancreas, spleen,
appendix, uterus,
ovaries, and the
peritoneal surfaces.
Surgery to remove tumors
is thorough and aggressive
with the goal of preserving
organs whenever possible.
The doctor carefully examines
the abdominal region,
quadrant by quadrant, searching
for and removing tumors.
With great care, the
doctor uses highly
specialized surgical
techniques to strip the tumors
from the peritoneal
surfaces and organs
and seal small blood vessels.
All of the visible
tumors are removed.
Next, the doctor administers
the HIPEC or heated chemotherapy
treatment, with a goal of
killing any remaining cancer
cells that cannot be seen.
Tubes and temperature
probes are placed
into the abdominal cavity.
The doctor briefly
closes the skin
of the abdomen with sutures.
The abdominal cavity is
flooded with a solution
that includes
chemotherapy drugs.
This solution is heated.
The tubes and probes are
connected to a machine.
This controls the temperature
and flow of the solution.
The heated chemotherapy
solution is continuously
circulated throughout
the abdominal cavity
so that the cavity
is uniformly exposed
to heat and chemotherapy.
The combination of
heat and chemotherapy
causes the solution to kill
microscopic cancer cells.
Gentle shaking is
applied to the abdomen
to help the solution
distribute to all surfaces
within the abdomen.
Following the HIPEC
treatment, the fluid
is drained from the
abdominal cavity.
The abdomen is reopened and the
tubes and probes are removed.
At this time, any necessary
reconstructive surgery
is performed.
For example, the doctor may need
to reconnect a resected colon.
Finally the doctor closes
the abdominal incision.
The surgery and HIPEC
treatment together
may take 6 to 12
hours to complete.